Trascrizione:
"Io mezza cieca e tu sorda,
direi che insieme facciamo
una persona normale".
È con questo spirito che sommava
la mia ipoacusia e la sua forte miopia,
è così che ci descriveva mia madre,
sempre attenta a sdrammatizzare
gli aspetti più seri della nostra vita.
Così io ho imparato a sorridere!
La mia storia è iniziata
nell’estate del ’79:
quell’estate, mia madre
si è ammalata di rosolia
e sapeva che quella malattia avrebbe
potuto compromettere la mia salute,
ma decise di portare a termine
la gravidanza ugualmente.
Irresponsabile, diranno alcuni,
coraggiosa, diranno altri.
Ma alla mia nascita sembrava
che la rosolia mi avesse risparmiata.
La sordità mi è stata
diagnosticata in ritardo,
nel nostro lontano
sud-ovest della Sardegna,
e mi hanno messo gli apparecchi acustici
all’età di cinque anni.
Immaginate i miei primi cinque anni:
“pascolavo” sulle parole.
In famiglia mi chiamavano
la “nostra cinesina”,
perché parlavo a monosillabi:
”Ci ua ua ua, ci ua ua ua”.
Lo dicevo con una tale
convinzione e naturalezza
che i miei genitori mi raccontano
che quando ho iniziato ad articolare
le mie prime frasi complete,
erano dispiaciuti di aver perso
il mio linguaggio “speciale”.
Ai miei tempi non esisteva
lo screening neonatale:
nel mio caso io non sentivo
proprio niente,
percepivo le vibrazioni,
leggevo le labbra;
e nessuno me lo ha mai insegnato,
si dice che sia
l’istinto di sopravvivenza.
Vedevo bocche,
leggevo spesso i nomi
dei miei fratelli e sorella,
ripetuti tante volte
che mi veniva facile pronunciarli:
Gianluca con Ian, novella con Noi,
Federico con Fidi.
Tutto questo grazie all'aiuto
degli apparecchi acustici:
ai tempi erano analogici,
cioè semplificavano i suoni
e il suono della voce
non era naturale, ma distorto,
come quando cerchi di ascoltare
un programma in radio
e il segnale non è forte,
lo senti gracchiare.
Ecco, i miei apparecchi erano così!
Ma per migliorare
la performance dell'ascolto
dovevo allenare il cervello e l'udito,
e poi dovevo ricorrere alla logopedia.
Quindi mia madre mi aiutava
a riconoscere alcuni suoni,
ad ascoltare determinate
vibrazioni delle corde vocali
con le mani poggiate sul collo
e a pronunciarle in maniera corretta.
Erano esercizi molto faticosi,
impegnativi per una bambina
di cinque anni.
Fortunatamente, mi rapportavo
coi miei coetanei tranquillamente
e i miei amici sono stati
fondamentali per me.
Poi lo sport,
la mia predisposizione a praticarlo
e il mio carattere solare
mi facevano fare tante cose.
Ma
non mi facevo problemi
perché ero una ragazzina
con difficoltà di udito,
avevo un caratterino
e non mi lasciavo intimidire da nessuno,
mi facevo valere
e questo mi ha dato la possibilità
di essere integrata nel gruppo.
Ma nessuno poteva vedere e comprendere
i miei continui sforzi a capire tutto,
proprio perché ero bravissima
a mascherare le mie emozioni,
su questo ero bravissima.
Ora mi viene tutto spontaneo:
se non capisco una cosa, chiedo,
ma molte persone
nella mia stessa condizione
hanno difficoltà a chiedere
agli altri di ripetere,
per paura o vergogna
di essere giudicati stupidi.
Alle scuole superiori
avevo alcuni professori
che mi mettevano voti bassi
con la giustificazione
che io ero sempre distratta.
Io distratta?
Semplicemente, non riuscivo a seguire
una lezione di tre ore di seguito,
perdevo il filo -
- e non ero la sola, comunque.
Allora chiedevo
ai miei compagni di aiutarmi
e durante le interrogazioni
mi passavano dei fogli di nascosto.
Solo a ripensarci mi viene da sorridere,
perché è proprio
grazie a quella complicità
che ho rafforzato
la mia personalità e fiducia.
Sono stati i miei primi sottotitoli.
In famiglia pensavamo
che quel tipo di scuola
non riusciva a valorizzarmi
e infatti cambiai scuola
e mi diplomai all’artistico,
scoprendo la mia vera propensione
per il disegno e la manualità,
che pensavo di non avere.
Ma intanto avevo una passione innata:
la pallavolo.
In casa, noi cinque figli siamo cresciuti
con un pallone in mano,
e i nostri maestri sono stati
mio nonno e per me Mila e Shiro.
Si, quelli dei cartoni giapponesi
che volavano con le loro schiacciate
sulla rete facendomi sognare.
Negli anni ’80, la TV
non aveva i sottotitoli
e io mi immaginavo i loro dialoghi.
Ho sentito l’adrenalina in casa
con lo sguardo di Mila
che sfidava le avversarie,
con quella sicurezza che avrebbe fatto
punto e cambiato la partita.
La adoravo per la sua determinazione,
perché credeva tanto in se stessa
e mi faceva credere in me stessa.
Questo lo sottolineo!
Così mi sono innamorata di questo sport,
lo pratico ancora,
ovviamente da pensionata,
ma quella che rimane
è la passione per lo sport,
che mi ha permesso
di costruire tante amicizie
e di compensare il mio difetto.
Col tempo ho capito che
se hai qualcosa in meno
e qualcos'altro in più,
puoi compensare l’uno con l‘altro,
ristabilendo l’equilibrio dentro di te
e con tutti gli altri.
Ho sofferto tanto per i sacrifici,
grazie agli insegnamenti.
Quando pensi di non farcela,
e se non riesci a fare qualcosa,
provaci!
Solo così potrai scoprire
quando e dove è il tuo limite
e come cercare di superarlo.
Tutti i miei successi sportivi
mi hanno portato
in tutte le parti del mondo,
ma non hanno risolto tutti i problemi
che una persona sorda affronta
nella vita quotidiana.
Vi racconto uno dei miei tanti episodi:
una sera, rientrando a casa,
vengo travolta da una macchina
durante un sorpasso.
Stordita e con un ronzio in testa,
vengo trasportata subito
al Pronto Soccorso:
lì con le mani che mi tremavano
chiedo a un operatore del 118
di chiamare i miei genitori,
dando per scontato che l’avrebbero fatto.
La sua risposta distaccata:
“Mi dispiace, non è di mia competenza”.
In quel momento, io ho sentito
tutto il peso della mia sordità addosso
e nonostante tutto ho ringraziato
con un sorriso amaro.
Ci metto dieci minuti
per digitare un messaggio,
solo per dire:
“Ho avuto un incidente, ma sto bene”.
Io adoro l’ironia,
e attualmente convivo con il mio compagno:
lui è siciliano e io sarda,
direi un bel connubio.
La sera, ognuno di noi
regola la sveglia per il giorno dopo
e Francesco mi fa: “Amore,
che la metti a fare se sei sorda?”.
La mia risposta è: “Amore,
la metto per te così mi svegli”.
Oppure, quando fa il ruffiano
tutto innamorato con me:
“Tesoro, lo senti il mio amore?”.
E io: “No amore, sono sorda, lo sai!”.
Insomma, quando si tratta di sordità,
bisogna essere ironici,
per tranquillizzare
le persone che hai di fronte
ed è l’unico modo
per non metterle in soggezione.
È un paradosso che una persona sorda
debba mettere gli altri
a loro agio di fronte a lui
e prevedere le loro difficoltà!
La frase che adoro tanto
e che dico spesso è:
“Quando Dio distribuiva
due orecchie e una bocca,
per ascoltare di più
e per parlare di meno,
io ero in fila aspettando il mio turno,
ma si deve essere distratto,
perché io parlo di più e sento di meno".
L’evoluzione della tecnologia
è diventata anche
evoluzione del mio ascolto:
prima quasi tutto con la
lettura labiale e qualche gesto,
poi l’ascolto è diventato più attento
e la percezione dei suoni è migliorata.
Quando ti dicono che dimenticano
che hai problemi di udito
e si scusano perché non sembri
così tanto sorda,
certamente per me è un bel complimento,
perché è proprio
grazie al lavoro di logopedia
e all’ausilio degli apparecchi,
che riesco a mimetizzarmi
con le persone udenti
ed essere parte della società
a tutti gli effetti.
Ma la condizione permane,
la sordità è qui per sempre
e questo, la maggior parte della gente
non capisce che può influire
sullo stato psicologico
della persona che sente poco.
Con la pandemia, le bocche coperte
hanno penalizzato molte persone
nella mia stessa condizione:
immaginate quando cerco di interagire
negli uffici pubblici,
in banca, alle poste ecc.
e devo chiedere
di abbassare la mascherina.
Alcuni pensano di essere su Candid Camera,
e si guardano attorno come a dire:
“Ma è uno scherzo?”.
Insomma, la solita tragicommedia.
Adesso gli apparecchi acustici digitali
permettono di ottimizzare i suoni,
e di saperli anche distinguere.
Un tempo, io ho odiato tanto
i miei apparecchi acustici
e li odiavo talmente tanto
che trovavo mille scuse
per non indossarli,
erano degli intrusi per me,
una parte estranea che non mi apparteneva,
li odiavo talmente tanto
che mi chiedevo del perché ero sorda.
Un giorno una persona mi ha chiesto
se avevo mai sognato
o pensato di volere essere
una persona udente.
Sinceramente no, non riesco a immaginare
la mia vita da persona udente,
perché non saprei nemmeno chi sarei.
Dopo 35 anni,
i miei apparecchi acustici
li amo, li amo da morire
e non riuscirei mai a separarmene,
perché sono parte del mio cuore,
parte di ogni mia giornata.
Se sto senza è perché decido
di estraniarmi:
è come chiudere gli occhi
e dimenticare tutto.
Un attimo e si ricomincia.
Solo l’accettazione di te
ti permette di essere felice
di ciò che sei e di ciò che fai.
Bisogna quindi trovare
un equilibrio dentro di sè
per essere felice o triste
come chiunque altro!